giants are in nationals park washington
looks like a very nice day the giants
atop the national league west
taking on the washington nationals the
fourth game of the series the giants
with a chance to make it three out of
four before they head home and they get
joe ross joe has made two career starts
against san fran one and one with a 360
era and the o2 now
swing
and a miss
as you mentioned bob nice and easy 95 by
you yes
got back from the injured list yesterday
and played game one
that ball is smoked down the right field
line and
off the wall
and yes will
make it into second with a double he's
got speed and even though the ball was
played cleanly off the wall by soto an
easy double for yasremski
1-1
and this one in front of the base runner
into trey turner
plenty of time two down
and crawford will pop it up right side
ryan zimmerman
he's gonna catch it in the coaches box
cueto in his 10th start of the year he's
got a 3.7 overall earned run average now
schwarber one for six with a solo home
or career against cueto
schwarber high in the air right center
c
u
later he's done it again
that's number 11 rbi number 28.
and quito has given up another home run
feels like he heard you bob
right on cue instant offense from your
lead off hitter
[Applause]
well the back barrel goes a lot farther
than the baseball and an errant throw by
wilmer flores
pulling brandon belt way off the bat
josh couple of knocks and an rbi
big double yesterday in game one
that's going to get through
brian zimmerman's going to make the turn
and keep on going eyeballing duggar the
center fielder and the nats have three
base winners two hits here in the first
popped up
and caught
by belt not that we had even a clue
where that ball was going
delivers first pitch hit off the foot of
kuwait and deflects into an open area of
the infield and avila will have himself
an infield head
roble is trying to push a bunt for the
base hit what is going on
with the giants defense today
the best in the national league and
that's their second miscue
i think it looked like johnny kind of
jammed his foot on that play he's
probably gonna get a moment he's bending
over now checking things out he
he squares
belt tagged
but he got it done
well here comes that power hitting lead
off the guy again
schwarber lifting one to right center
see
you
later
this is a fastball elevated 95 miles an
hour he got all on top of that one now
the leadoff guy has four runs batted in
[Applause]
soto just guides it up the middle off
the side of the mound long throw and one
is going to beat it out brandon crawford
had a long way to go and juan saul
is going to lay out his first knock of
this series
zimmerman safe on an error and that's a
pick off cradle picks off soto and now
harrison 02.
look at that 02 swing
93 hitter and he got all of it the other
way
and that throws right into the runner
josh all right brandon belt kind of
moving over the top of harrison to try
to get that errant throw
strike three called with the chain jack
and this one skyed left side trey tuner
turns his back to home plate sprinting
in the left hand the over the ball cap
one-handed basket catch
very well done
the concentration there
able to corral it
who's probably telling cars for why i'm
all the way out here
that's your ball
jammed
still a base hit
and victor robles is aboard
trey would love a two-out knock to pick
up his 31st rbi now the pitch to turner
right-handed batter and he hits a fly
ball to right yes over to his left a bit
near the foul line he's got it inning
over
adam reaching hit the ball well castro
picks it off squares up great throw
zimmerman the stretch one hour
starling was ready for it
the best part about it bob here he
gathered himself
replaced his feet make a good strong
throw to zim
back fastball
brandon belt frozen
two down on jill ross's fourth strikeout
sway animus
on two hits
five strikeouts
and seven ground ball outs
joe ross dominates through five and then
that's
great starting pitching josh harrison is
single to left center and single to
right he's two for two
pitch to harrison line to left toward
the line and down for a base hit
charging over tockman again and harrison
on his way to second and throw will not
nearly be in time and josh harrison is
three for three of the game
two balls two strikes to castro
and he will drop one into left center
that'll add to the nationals lead in
fact it's all the way to the wall and
starlin is starting to pile up some
extra base hits now
five-nothing nationals on his second rbi
in this series
swinging a miss for strike three
but the gnats add to their lead
that warmed us up quite a bit talkman to
center field
that chases robles back all the way back
and robles will leap and make the catch
there's gabe just they might as well
take it take a peek at it yeah so they
are going to check
great effort here
yeah it hit the wall they hit the wall
that's a double
yeah it's a double
busted back desoto will get there both
sides of the baseball today in the
washington nationals
are a highlight reel 3-1
a damaged count betray gets nothing with
which to work
and johnny cueto has walked the bases
full here and he will be done for the
day
this be quite a test for jose alvarez
he's a part of this giants bullpen hobby
that has pitched a lot better here and
jose's kind of gotten his season turned
around he's been throwing the ball well
on the ground that could be two solano
crawford double play
one and two
right in there with the swing back
fastball
and now joe ross has struck out seven
right in there
why brandon beld is really trying to
feel something in the batter's box joe
ross has been able to execute that pitch
every time to him during his
four at bat so far today
up there hacking
castro has to give with it short throw
inning over
take a stretch
joe ross
one of the best starts of his career
harrison reaching
four for four yes sir
dropping one into right center
josh harrison
is now six
for eight
in this series
then he throws another
schwarber long way to go ball twisting
foul and he gets there
then he drops it when he makes contact
with the barrier
swing and a miss on a slider down and in
yeah i like what kyle did there he's
like i'm gonna not make the play there
so joe ross can get nine for strikeouts
on the attack
schwarber coming for this one and it
gets just under it looked like kyle had
it measured
and vosler into second base with one out
here in the eighth
and he's gonna get him on a pop-up to
center
eight great
for joe ross
he is slinging sammy today
one and two
on the hop trey has it
game over and the nats get the split
brilliant pitching by joe ross and sam
clay gets three quick outs